[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine leckere schokokuss
torte ich habe mir gedacht wir machen
eine braun tatorte im prinzip braucht
sie den baum der regel gar nicht dafür
denn es stellt den bau titel einfach als
torte nach unten habe ich einen leckeren
schoko boden darüber eine kurzschicht
und darüber eine pizza danach richtig
lecker und ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
die selbstgemachten bautz machen und
dann getötet damit dekorieren und die
selbstgemachten bounty gibt's ja schon
bereits auf meinem kanal los geht's
jetzt aber erstmal mit dem schoko teig
für den teig verwende ich 250 g weiche
butter 150 gramm zucker eine prise salz
etwas vanille extrakt 14 war meier 60
milliliter milch oder kokos lecker 40
gramm kakaopulver 200 gramm mehl und
einen teelöffel backpulver ich nehme
zuerst die weiche butter und die kommt
in eine rührschüssel
und hier ist eigentlich jetzt nur
wichtig dass alle zutaten im zimmer warm
sind
damit der teig schön homogen wird und
nicht gruselig wird dann kommt da die
prise salz dazu der zucker und etwas
vanille extrakt dann werden die zutaten
in etwa fünf minuten cremig verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt ist die butter zucker masse schön
cremig und jetzt kommentiert die eier
nacheinander dazu und das ist auch ganz
wichtig damit die masse nicht gerinnt
also immer ein einrühren
etwa eine halbe minute und dann erst das
nächste
[Musik]
jetzt vermisse ich noch etwas
kakaopulver mit dem mehl und backpulver
säbel die zutaten in den teig und dann
kommt hier noch die milch statt so
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den teig bereits immer
eine backform einfüllen und dann wieder
gebacken
[Musik]
der tortenboden ist jetzt gut abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich bereits die füllung
zu bereiten und die füllung die erinnert
wirklich an die füllung von bounty für
die bau- und erfüllung verwende ich 600
milliliter milch 120 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 100 gramm weizen gries
200 gramm kokosraspeln und 100 gramm
butter gebe ich zuerst die männchen
einen topf und lasse darin kurz
aufkochen
wenn die milch am hoch kocht dann den
herunterschalten
dann gebe ich hier manuell extract dazu
den zucker grieß und auch die kokons
raspe und jetzt kann ich das ganze
einfach bei mittlerer hitze so etwa ein
bis zwei minuten lang ziehen lassen so
dass einfach der krise ein bisschen
quälen kann und die milch sozusagen
eingezogen wird
dann kommt jetzt hier noch die butter
dazu den herd kann ich jetzt schon
ausmachen
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch
einen teil der milch austauschen mit
kokosmilch
aber ich finde dann immer ein bisschen
zu schwer also nimmt auf jeden fall
nicht zu viel kokosmilch dann versteckt
sich zwar der kokos geschmack aber wie
gesagt manchmal gehts noch einmal ein
bisschen zu schwer
jetzt schön durchrühren damit die butter
schmelzen und dann ist die füllung schon
fertig und kann direkt auf den kuchen
gegossen werden
da habe ich einen tortenring bereits
umgestellt
[Musik]
jetzt schön glatt streichen
mit 20 tote bei raumtemperaturen
bisschen abkühlen und dann kommt sie in
den kühlschrank und muss einmal komplett
durch kühlen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte gut durchgeführt und
jetzt kommen die schoko schicht dafür
verwende ich 200 gramm sahne 200 gramm
zucker schokolade ein paar cocos chips
und hier habe ich noch bauen
es geht jetzt eigentlich ganz schnell
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die sahne die
kommt in den topf ohne wird ganz kurz
aufgekocht
[Musik]
und wenn die sahne den kopf ich schalte
ich den hut auf dann kommt die
schokolade rein belaste kurz eine halbe
minute etwas stehen und kann dann die
garage entstanden ist schön durchführen
[Musik]
die garage ist jetzt nur noch lauwarm
also ich hätte ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen und jetzt gibt sich die hälfte
davon über die abgekühlte torte ist auch
ganz wichtig dass die cocos masse
wirklich ganz kalt ist ihr könnt sie
auch kurz in den gefrierschrank stellen
und jetzt vorsichtig da drauf und die
hälfte lasse ich übrig für die deko und
das hier verstreiche ich jetzt
[Musik]
die jungs fangen schon an hinter der
kamera war der platz aber jungs ich muss
ich leider enttäuschen die torte muss
erst gekühlt werden jetzt kommt die
torte für ungefähr noch mal eine halbe
stunde bis stunde in den kühlschrank und
die restliche ganache die fülle ich
jetzt um stellt sie auch in den
kühlschrank damit sie auch ein bisschen
festhalten kann
für die sache also für die stoffe bisher
müssen noch warten
jetzt ist die torte gut durch gekühlt
die ghanas habe ich jetzt bereits schon
vor 20 minuten aus dem kühlschrank
geholt wie darf halt nicht zu kalt sein
jetzt wird sie einmal kurz durch gerührt
die wird nämlich relativ fest das habe
ich ihnen spritzbeutel mit großer stimme
und dafür ich jetzt getrieben
[Musik]
kann ich die torte herauslösen ganz
vorsichtig
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich einen trotten einteiler
und materie ist die torte weise die
zwölf stückchen keine cd 12 tupfen
draufsetzen
jetzt kann ich die torte mit kokos chips
oder kokosraspeln und bauen tisch
dekorieren
[Musik]
moore hat gesagt heute möchte ich nicht
mehr probieren
also stelle ich die torte abgedeckt im
kühlschrank und dann kann er morgen früh
probieren und ihr dürft dann schauen was
also zu sagen ich bin mal gespannt
also die torte lässt sich auch wunderbar
vorbereiten und im kühlschrank an einen
tag lagern bis morgen
[Musik]
so moment hat sich so gewünscht jetzt
regt sie zum frühstück durchgequält ja
hier ist doch wieder im rat dafür ihre
probieren ja vgh und statische
hollandica boden kokos und schokolade
aus dem ich übrigens auch mal alexium
alexium war dem spiegel schenke ich mal
kokosnuss ich glaube ich es auch sowas
mag man es oder man es nicht einmal
getraut weil ja ich glaube es gibt
menschen die mögen kokosnuss gibt
menschen die hessen kokos und gehört auf
jeden fall denn die hände machen wer von
euch wissen
ok eine person ist da genau richtig kalt
war und die torte fertigt seine 307 200
nur eine von drei schmeckt toll finden
das nicht zu süßlich ja ich hab's
eingeschenkt wurde das kann man wirklich
cool also wenn jetzt ein bisschen süße
mag macht ruhig ein bisschen mehr zu
bereiten
aber ansonsten bin ich erst wenn ihr
normalen werktagen gleich kritischer
nein wie die normale menschen seid dann
macht genauso nach jetzt richtig perfekt
wirklich schön schokolade der boni die
creme und des krise liege von der kur
und kreisstadt in metten ich hatte ja
mal dass beiden unserer nicht in der
ersten oder in der zweiten wohnung hatte
ich mal bounty ist selber gemacht
erinnert sich noch und ja der zweiten
wohnung war das ganz am anfang und da
habe ich die füllung dieser bauen sie
ist einfach abgewandelt für den kuchen
und die konsistenz der ist doch cremig
also der teig ist es keine lockerer teil
sondern eher ein festerer schoko teil
aber es passt so gibt man bei youtube
direkt mal bauen sie ein der müssen
normalerweise sofort auch ein video vom
ja schon älteres mittel aus der eigenen
küche gern ja da war schon normal
ja aber da hatten wir halt kein bug feld
und keiner insel und deswegen
konnte ich da keine koch videos machen
sagen sie mal umgezogen für ja und dann
wurde uns unsere wohnung zu klein mit
den ganzen mitarbeitern und deswegen
sind wir hierher gezogen
hier finde ich sehr schön aber auch gern
jetzt wohnen wir hier und arbeiten hier
das ist schön die kaffeemaschine macht
sich sauber das ist auch okay also falls
ihr die bauern täter hatte nach machen
wollt dann geht auf meinem blog auf 6 -
blog.de
da stehen die zutaten menge noch mal für
euch ihr müsst nicht dem rezept
mitschreiben im video sondern können
einfach alles ausdrucken oder online
speicher ja und was ja auch cool finde
ich also wie ist dies nicht zu süß die
ist nicht zu mächtig aber ihr werdet es
nicht mehr als ein stück schaffen
ja also das heißt das ding machen mit
4000 viel spaß beim nachmachen und
torten wünsche gerne in die kommentare
reist zum nächsten mal 20 gipfel soll
ich euch heißt es packen gleich wieder
alexander für die kinderuni geschneidert
worden
[Musik]